the batman is back and better than ever
at 2019's dc fandom event the first
teaser of the batman was released to the
world and it promised to be a spectacle
from the get-go now that some lucky
audiences have been able to check out
the movie it's confirmed that this film
is everything it was suspected of being
a riveting dark thriller with one of the
best batman's ever to done the cow even
before fans were able to get themselves
in seats critics and press members were
able to see matt reeves take on the dark
knight and they too for the most part
were beyond impressed some of the first
reactions to the batman called it
sensational gripping and one hell of a
movie when it comes to our newest caped
crusader it was also said that robert
pattinson might just be your new
favorite batman of course critics and
audiences don't always align unless
we're talking about christopher nolan's
the dark knight so let's see what the
fans had to say on twitter about the
batman and if it lives up to all the
hype what is the price for your blind
bag
as to be expected the biggest thing fans
are talking about on twitter is robert
pattinson's portrayal of batman and
bruce wayne which are two very different
things by the way it's hard to find the
criticism of baton sent on the bird app
with many praising his performance as
the dark knight
one user kept it simple writing i admit
i'm in love with robert pattinson's
batman meanwhile another excitedly
exclaimed just saw the batman and
honestly robert pattinson was born to
play this role damn moviegoers are
ecstatic over pattinson's ability to
capture the essence of the eponymous
character as well as his billionaire
counterparts
one fan made a definitive statement
tweeting yeah robert pattinson is the
best bruce wayne batman combo the rest
of the cast is being said to have
delivered incredible performances as
well one fan could barely keep their
excitement contained writing pattinson
[ __ ] killed it paul dana was riddler
was straight out of a horror movie colin
farrell john turturro zoe kravitz and
jeffrey wright were all phenomenal matt
reeves made a masterpiece of a movie
holy sh
oh take it easy sweetheart while the
batman may be a standalone movie there
was no way this new adventure wasn't
going to be compared to the dark knight
which many long hailed is the best
superhero movie of all time fans who
were able to catch the new film early
started comparing it to the christopher
nolan film right away
one fan commented the batman is the
second best superhero movie of all time
just behind the dark knight another fan
lapped on more praise saying matt reeves
gave me the batman film of my dreams
something i've been waiting for since
batman the animated series i've never
seen something and i've been absolutely
sure of something but i'm 100 sure this
is the best batman film we've ever
gotten and my absolute favorite ever
overall it seems like the batman has
cemented itself as one of the greatest
comic book movies of all time while it
technically is a superhero movie it
doesn't necessarily feel like one the
batman is an action thriller to its core
and fans couldn't be happier with it
some of the comments included 10 out of
10 this is a live-action batman film
i've always wanted
the batman was so amazing i'm shaking
just walked out of the batman and they
have no words
they nailed the batman from start to
finish
the batman is a masterpiece one of the
best superhero movies ever all in all
fans of the dark knight are not going to
be disappointed with the batman which
sounds from our reactions like it's been
worth the years of hype when that light
hits the sky
it's not just a call
that's so mourning
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]